[MUSIC PLAYING]
MALE SPEAKER 1: Shanghai GDG
is a very interesting
developer community.
FEMALE SPEAKER 1: I'm
glad somebody
has asked this question.
MALE SPEAKER 2: This is where
the magic happens.
FEMALE SPEAKER 2: This is
primarily a question and
answer show.
So if any of you out there would
like to ask questions.
MANO MARKS: Hi.
I'm Mano Marks.
I'm a developer advocate on
the Google Maps Developer
Relations team.
I'm here with Brendan Kenny,
who is also on
the team with me.
And we're here to talk to you
today about some of the latest
experiments that we've been
doing with incorporating HTML5
onto Google Maps.
So these are very much work in
progress kind of things,
building off of some things you
may have seen earlier in
the summer when Brendan talked
about his canvas layer work
he's been doing.
So do you want to describe,
just briefly,
what we've been doing?
BRENDAN KENNY: Sure.
So the most recent thing we've
been doing is taking a look at
how to load, parse, and display
some of the most
common GeoData formats.
So especially looking at
shapefiles and KML.
And the main problem that you
run into if you want to parse
it-- well, actually, there's
several stages of problems.
The first thing you have to
do is actually load them.
And you actually wrote
that part.
So if you want to
talk about that.
MANO MARKS: So one of the things
that we looked at back
in the spring is looking at a
pre-parsing data on a server
and then passing it into the
browser for display.
And we've had some really good
samples about doing that.
And it's been really fun.
But we want to look at doing
pure JavaScript in the browser
solutions for this.
And so what I've been looking
at doing is loading in
shapefiles and KML files and
then displaying them on top of
Google Maps by parsing them in
JavaScript and then passing
that onto the canvas layer.
So the shapefiles are
binary files.
Actually, so those of you who
know about shapefiles would
know that it's an open spec,
high-end GIS software, and
lots of GIS software, basically,
can produce
shapefiles.
There's many files that compose
the single shapefile.
I was looking particularly at
the .shp, which describes the
geometries.
and the .dbf, which describes
the attribute data.
We aren't dealing at this
point with projections,
although that's something
we want to
deal with in the future.
And so loading those in, HTML5
allows you to load in using
XML HTTP requests.
You can actually now a
load in binary files.
So previously, people had dealt
with this by loading it
in as a string, passing a string
that is basically a
binary string, and then
doing fancy parsing.
But you can actually load in
these shapefile formats as
binary files instead
of as text.
And then I compared that with
using KML, which is an XML
data format.
It's actually the most common
geographic data
format in the world.
There are about a billion of
them on the web right now.
And so what we did was we took
some zip code boundary data
from the US Census.
So taking the TIGER/line data,
and we're looking at 100
polygons in Northern California,
basically just to
get a sense of how
that would work.
And then I used a couple of
open-source libraries.
There's shp.js, dbf.js for
parsing each of those pieces.
And then also using JSTS, which
is a JavaScript port of
the Java Topology Suite, to
do the triangulation.
So then why don't you talk a
little bit more about what
happens then.
BRENDAN KENNY: Sure.
So we can take a look at an
example here that I'm running.
This is loading a shapefile of
those zip codes and/or--
what are they?
The census something--
MANO MARKS: Yeah, zip code
boundaries from--
BRENDAN KENNY: Anyway,
basically zip codes.
And so this is just loading the
first 100 zip code areas
in that file and then
displaying them.
And this is actually doing the
convex hull of that, so the
smallest convex polygon that
encompasses that zip code,
which is useful for a lot of
questions about that area.
And so what we're doing here
is, as Mano said, we are
actually using XML
HTTP requests to
bring in that file.
You set the response type as
array buffer so you can get it
as directly the binary data, and
then slipping through it
and parsing it to get at
the actual data points.
And from there, we pass it to
JSTS right now to do the
triangulation.
So the problem here is that we
want to use WebGL to display
on top of a map.
If you've seen some of our
previous live sessions, you've
heard us talk about
canvas layer.
And we had a session at Google
I/O where we also talked about
it, just basically, putting a
WebGL canvas on top of a map
so that we have access to that
hardware-accelerated, super
fast, geometry-drawing
capability on top of a map.
The problem is that WebGL is
intentionally meant to be low
level and provide primitives
that are extremely fast but
that you have to then put
together to do something more
complicated.
And in this case, it only
draws triangles.
And the problem is, when you
have a big polygon, usually in
a shapefile, it's just--
MANO MARKS: Well, you need
points, lines, or triangles.
BRENDAN KENNY: Sorry,
yes, yes, yes.
But the only fill shape
is a polygon.
You can't do quadrilaterals or
any kind of higher number of
vertex shapes.
So in this case, the shapefile
just has these polylines to
define the borders
of the zip codes.
And so we actually have to
triangulate them to get them
into a format that
we can draw.
And right now, we're
using JSTS.
We're taking a look at--
actually, I started porting
the live test, which is an
open source version of the
tessellation library from the
OpenGL utility library back
from 20 years ago.
But it's still one of the
best methods to do this.
And we'll all just have a nice
JavaScript library when that's
done, which'll be great.
So we can actually peek
in here in the code.
If we look at just a particular
record, we can see
the format that we get.
So once it's parsed and
triangulated, we get an array
of objects to draw.
And then within that, we just
have the information about--
there's this kind of primitive
level information.
So for that particular polygon
here, we've stored the actual
zip code and other information
about that.
And this could be anything.
So this was in the shapefile
already.
But it could be anything from
demographic data to a
reference to another shapefile
so we can pull in data that's
particular to that zip code
and cross-reference it.
Then we actually have
the binary data.
And if we drill down here, you
can see it's just a series of
latitude and longitudes that's
actually in normal lat/long
space that we then take
care of on the inside.
And then we have the
type polygon.
And so this is where we can
switch on things like
polylines and point data,
that sort of thing.
And finally, we just had this
uniform object that lets us--
if you're familiar with WebGL,
there's these uniform
variables, which is how you pass
data in on the triangle
level to say I want this
triangle red, or I want this
triangle associated
with this value.
And I can do whatever
I want in a shader.
And so that's how we
actually render it.
And then in canvas layer, we
just loop over this array of
polygons and just say load this
list of data and then
render that list of data.
And so I think right now we're
actually showing something
like 200,000 triangles.
So this is unsimplified data.
This is direct from
the shapefile.
And it's a little hard to see
when it's presented like this.
But it actually shows
at a full 60
frames a second on this.
I think this is like a two and
a half year-old machine.
So it's nothing too-- it's a
decent computer, but it runs
really well, is the thing
I'm getting at.
MANO MARKS: And as you can
see, these are rather
blobbish-looking polygons.
If you actually look at
polygons, you can actually
look up a particular zip
code, US zip code on
maps.google.com.
It'll highlight the
polygon for you.
We don't do that in the Maps
API at this point.
But they're much more
precise than this.
And that's because JSTS uses,
as Brendan mentioned, this
convex hull algorithm, which
creates a more simplified
polygon that contains
the polygon.
So you can see it looks
very roundish.
This doesn't work well at all
for concave polygons or
polygons that have holes in
then, which actually you can
tell that this does because
you can see there's
overlapping polygons.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, and if
you have polygons that
self-intersect, then you're
really in trouble.
In fact, I don't think-- or at
least we haven't found any
JavaScript triangulation
library that handles
self-intersection, which is
why we're turning towards
these other libraries, which
can be a little bit slower,
but are proven correct in almost
all situations and are
also extremely numerically
stable and that sort of thing.
So it's not that exciting, but
you can actually see the same
thing over here.
And this is parsing
the KML file.
And so this--
you're not using a
binary load here.
You're using something slightly
different, right?
MANO MARKS: No, I just
load it in as XML.
BRENDAN KENNY: OK.
MANO MARKS: And we get better
performance with the binary,
loading in a binary shape file
and parsing that than the KML.
Not significantly, but we're
only working with about 100
polygons here.
So I think you'd see much longer
load times if you were
doing all of California.
BRENDAN KENNY: Right.
Oh, yeah, that's a good point.
I mean, the slowest part is
triangulation because these
things are tens of thousands
of vertices.
And so you have to--
at the very least, you're
going to have
that order of triangles.
And often, you have much more
if it's more complicated.
But with KML, you have to parse
the XML, so the browser
takes care of that.
And then you walk it.
You use the browser's
API to actually walk
it, which is nice.
You get all this nice correction
of the data.
And the parsing engine takes
care of everything.
Whereas if your shapefile is
malformed, you're in trouble.
We can actually take a
look at the different
file formats here.
Here's the KML.
And it's about what you would
expect with KML, just lots and
lots of coordinates.
But what's kind of cool is we
can come over here and see the
binary representation
of the shapefile.
And this is what
we're loading.
So you don't have to deal
with a bunch of XML--
I don't know.
What should we call it?
Verbosity?
MANO MARKS: Verbosity, yeah.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, so
it's nicely packed
into this binary data.
On the other hand, it's very
much like load this byte.
And in that byte, it describes
how many of the next bytes are
going to be into this
coordinate.
And so right now, I would say
that it works pretty well.
We use what's called a data
view, which is kind of an
NDN-independent view of this
data, whereas array buffers
are NDN-dependent, which
doesn't really
matter right now.
But someday, computers
might switch again.
Or you might have something over
the network which is the
opposite of what you'd expect.
So dataview takes care
of that for you.
And there's a bunch of nice
libraries that deal with that
sort of thing.
MANO MARKS: Yeah, so definitely
based on current
experience, I would say if you
were doing a project and you
just want to display data that
you already had, I would
pre-triangulate it and push
it down to the browser
and do it that way.
But this would allow you to do
things like have people drag
and drop their own shapefiles
onto a map to view what their
own data would look like
in conjunction
with yours, for instance.
So this is a good technique.
We're going to work on refining
these libraries to
get them so that we have
a better triangulation.
We can handle polygons with
holes and also increasing
their performance.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, so
triangulation is good.
Simplification is good, too.
WebGL has pretty amazing
performance.
But it's not magic.
If you have 500 million
triangles, it's not going to
run very well.
But if you can now simplify that
on the server side, or
beforehand, you make that
a whole lot easier.
And then you can start doing fun
things because you have a
large performance window left
for you, where you can start
styling things, and animating
things, and doing
all sorts of craziness.
MANO MARKS: Right.
BRENDAN KENNY: So, Mano,
we're getting
close to our time here.
Do you want to talk about
how a high-level view?
Why is this interesting?
Why would we want to do this
sort of thing as opposed to
just loading your KML through
as a KML layer.
MANO MARKS: So one thing to
think about is the sort of
difference between server-side
rendering of layers and
client-side rendering.
And server-side rendering gives
you tremendous power.
You can push down the pipe
just the bare minimum of
exactly what you need.
And then the browser and the
computer that it's running on
don't have to do any work
to figure it out.
It's usually just displayed
as some sort of layer or--
sorry, an image layer.
In the case of a KML layer
in the Maps API,
it's a clickable raster.
But if you can do something on
the client side, then it can
actually be dynamically
interacted with.
You can change the data, change
the coloring, change
the display of the data, do
queries on it without having
to re-query the server and
pass data back down.
So these are kind of the
trade-offs you're making
between the client-side and
server-side rendering.
So yeah, I mean, obviously at
Google, we're very committed
to the cloud and having lots
of that sort of processing
happening there.
But I think with power of the
browser and the new APIs you
get with HTML5--
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah,
we can't ignore it.
It's still there.
MANO MARKS: Yeah, I think we're
going to continue have
this sort of dynamic tension
between the client- and
server-side rendering.
BRENDAN KENNY: Do we want to
dare do some live coding here?
MANO MARKS: Do we have time?
Do we have any YouTube questions
at this point?
BRENDAN KENNY: I don't
believe so.
MANO MARKS: We do.
We have some YouTube
questions.
BRENDAN KENNY: Oh, we do.
I'm just kidding.
MANO MARKS: OK, why
don't we take--
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, so
let's take a look.
So "what were the names of
those JS libraries?"
MANO MARKS: So JSTS--
BRENDAN KENNY: We'll link them
in the comments when we post
this video.
But for now--
MANO MARKS: JSTS for the
JavaScript Topology Suite.
It's a port of the Java
Topology Suite.
There is shape jut--
shp.js and dbf.js, both of
which are on GitHub.
And I think those are the only
ones that we've mentioned.
There's the one we're working
on porting and when we get
that out, but that's
but that's part of
the old OpenGL code.
BRENDAN KENNY: Right.
MANO MARKS: It's a port
of old C code.
Is there another question?
BRENDAN KENNY: Yes.
"Moral of the story-- maybe
better suited to points than
lines?"
MANO MARKS: Possibly.
I mean, points are things that
we've played with and have
been obviously really,
really powerful.
But I think polygons, once we
get the triangulation right, I
think that the polygons are
going to give you a lot more
powerful representation
of the data.
But yeah, I mean, clearly,
points and lines are less
computationally difficult
than triangles.
BRENDAN KENNY: Right.
I mean, so yeah.
I would say that they're
less difficult.
You can filter on them
more easily because
it's a discrete point.
MANO MARKS: Right.
BRENDAN KENNY: But if you
want to show an area,
then there's nothing--
you can try and do some kind
of heat map effect.
But that's not always
appropriate.
You know, If you want to show
the difference between
neighboring zip codes,
sometimes that's the
granularity of your data.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
BRENDAN KENNY: So it really
depends on what you're doing.
So I think that's the
only questions.
BRENDAN KENNY: We'll check
back if there's any more
questions on the video.
We'll check back in the next day
or so for more comments.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah,
that sounds good.
MANO MARKS: Cool.
Do we have time for your
live coding exercise?
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah,
I think so.
MANO MARKS: All right.
BRENDAN KENNY: So here what I'm
doing is showing you why
we might want to do this sort
of thing in the browser.
I'm thinking show
your code here.
We don't need these.
So what I'm doing is, I'm just
going to loop over these
records, these zip codes, and
just change the colors live.
And if I don't mess this up,
then oh, yes, right.
So I'm just looping
over these.
I'm taking the color.
I'm turning them green.
And then I need to do
canvasLayer.scheduleUpdate.
So canvas layer, by default,
doesn't redraw the screen
every time.
Right now, I haven't moved
the map at all.
There's no reason to redraw.
So I can call schedule update,
and that will make it so.
MANO MARKS: Right.
And that, of course, requires
no server calls or anything.
It's just happening right there
live in the browser.
BRENDAN KENNY: And there's
no reason why
this can't be dynamic.
This doesn't have to
be a stack number.
So I could do I divided by 100
and just make sure that that
is kept at one.
And now I can count up to full
green based on the index
within that array.
This is using the index.
But this could very well
be population.
This could be anything.
And it doesn't have
to be green.
It could be some combination
of colors.
It could be polka dotted.
It could be anything you want.
But the point is that
it's pretty much
instantaneous here.
There's nothing holding you back
from anything you want,
which is a pretty exciting
part of our WebGL.
All right, so that gives
us an idea of where
we are right now.
Did you have any last thoughts
before we wrap up?
MANO MARKS: No.
We'll continue work on this.
We'll push it out, push
out some changes.
In the next couple weeks, we'll
push out some samples
around this that you might be
interested in to monitor the
Google+ page and the Google
GeoDevelopers blog.
BRENDAN KENNY: Yeah, and when we
post the video, as we said,
check the links in the video
description, and we'll post
them on Google+, probably.
You can check out different
libraries we talk about,
including if you go to the Maps
V3 utility libraries, you
can check out canvas layer.
And it has some simple samples
in there to get you started.
And we're eager to see what
people come up with.
MANO MARKS: Yeah.
BRENDAN KENNY: Cool.
MANO MARKS: All right.
BRENDAN KENNY: Thanks a lot.
MANO MARKS: Thanks
a lot, guys.
[MUSIC PLAYING]